the story of an american woman in
afghanistan who faced an unimaginable
decision after the taliban took over she
could escape but only if she left behind
her mother and siblings that is until a
group of american strangers banded
together volunteering their time and
expertise to get around bureaucratic
roadblocks the woman spoke with senior
investigative correspondent catherine
herridge on the condition that we
protect her identity for safety
concerns this is my passport i don't
know if you can see it when we first met
this american mother we agreed to call
her angela and disguise her voice for
security reasons we are trapped in
afghanistan we have been here more than
three and a half months
she told us she was visiting family when
the taliban took over afghanistan
forcing her and her u.s born child into
hiding
as desperation swelled outside the kabul
airport in late august
as the last u.s military flights left
angela fought for more than a day to get
through the gates
until a suicide bomber attacked the
crowd we have no way out
we don't know what to do angela might
not have that much time her family might
not have that much time army veteran
brian kinsella first heard about angela
in august while volunteering at this
temporary evacuation effort based out of
a washington dc hotel
since kinsella has kept in nearly daily
contact to hear her family and their
kids screaming in the background it
actually gives me strength to try to
figure out a way to get angela out to
get her family out and use that as a
framework
to get many more people out in late
september angela said the state
department reached her because they
might have a flight they've called me
they know where i am they know my
situation
i've explained it to them so many times
but angela said the state department
told her they could not help her mother
or her siblings get on the flight
because they aren't american citizens
put yourself in her shoes and how easy
is it to just say
i'm willing to leave because we have a
blue passport
and you don't with angela's case stalled
kinsella enlisted the help of a
prominent law firm we're doing this pro
bono that means that we are giving our
time
for free
to help
angela and her family florian laveau and
a team of lawyers compiled a 118 page
file so that angela could apply for an
emergency entry into the u.s for the
benefit of her afghan siblings the
process is called humanitarian parole
because there is no u.s consulate in
afghanistan people who actually apply
for humanitarian parole actually have to
go to a third country
to go to your u.s consulate in those
third countries before they can actually
enter the us as our interview was cut
short by the spotty wi-fi angela said
all she had left was hope and faith god
can hear us he will support us he will
get us to a safer place
recently the pieces fell into place
after another group of volunteers came
together and scrambled a flight out of
afghanistan they flew to a country in
the middle east where her mother and
siblings with their paperwork filed can
now be vetted by the state department
and homeland security
the state department did not address
questions about angela's case or the
policy that divided her family a
spokesperson told us american citizens
remain their first priority and the
department is handling their needs on a
case-by-case basis for cbs saturday
morning i'm catherine herridge in
washington
i think the amazing thing is there are a
lot of people that are working for no
money right now to try to help people
and working round the clock and they
keep at it and that's what's so
important and all's well that ends well
in this case but you don't know how many
more cases there are like it or how many
there
may be in the future thanks to all those
volunteers